i wear a yamaka because i am proudly a
descendant of
abraham and isaac and jacob and moses
and david i am of their people
and i'm proud of the fact that israel is
in fact an
outlying area of western democracy and
if you have a problem with this you can
write off i want to begin today with a
simple
fact hey i wear a yamaka i've worn a
yamaka
since basically i'm old enough to
remember
and there are a lot of folks who asked
me why wariyama or why i didn't take off
the yamaka as i grew
in my career and the answer is because
this is who i am and this is what i do
it never occurred to me
to take off the yamaga and i've seen
over the course of the last week or so
this increase in anti-semitic attacks i
know a rabbi
who over the weekend explained that
he was at a supermarket and a man
walked up to him and to his son wearing
a hamas headband and started
cursing him cursing the jews and so a
lot of people
ask why i wear a yamaka i don't talk
about this frequently the reason i'm
talking about it now
is because i think it's really really
important to understand why jews wear a
yamaka the reason the jews wear yama can
make
ourselves identifiable right
theoretically we could hide although
historically that has not been
a winning strategy for jews the reason i
wear yamaka is for two reasons one
there's a religious reason going all the
way back to the talmud jews have warned
yama because they've covered their heads
out of submission to god and as a
reminder that god is above us at all
times
and the second reason is because no i'm
not going anywhere
and anybody who has a problem with it
can write off
okay the simple fact of the matter is
that i believe
in the promises that were made by god in
the bible i believe in those promises
i believe isaiah when he says isaiah 8
utsu 87
i believe that when when isaiah says
plan your plan
speak your words it will come to nothing
for god is with us i believe that
because i believe in biblical values
i believe in the first book of samuel
where samuel says
israel and the eternal of israel the
eternal god of israel
is no lie and that means the eternity
of the bible and biblical values those
are no lie either
i wear a yamaka because i am proudly a
descendant of
abraham and isaac and jacob and moses
and david i am of their people
i am of their ideals and of their values
and if you have a problem with it
not only do you have a problem with jews
you have a problem with the entire
judeo-christian line of values
i wear this yamaka because i am proud of
that identity
and you know what i'm proud that the
state of israel exists as well
i am proud that there is a state of
israel a state
that is a repository for jewish values i
am proud
that there are jews out there carrying
guns in defense of jews because for
thousands of years
that was not the case i am proud
as all civilized western people should
be that there is a state in the middle
east
that stands for the reality not only of
strong jews but stands for a
democratic truth stands for a democratic
state
you've heard that israel is some sort of
apartheid state let me give you a quick
stat
okay here is the number of jews in
israel right now 1.9
million arabs in the jewish state of
israel
okay there are 9 million people total in
the state of israel 1.9 million do you
know how many jews there are
in all of the so-called non-apartheid
states surrounding israel
there are a grand total of 10 jews in
egypt population
100 million there are zero jews in
jordan population 10 million
zero jews in saudi arabia population 34
million
100 jews in lebanon population 7 million
zero jews in syria population 17 million
four jews in iraq population 39 million
8 300 jews in iran population
83 million how many jews are there
living
under the wonderful auspices of the
palestinian authority
population 2.7 million zero how many are
living
under the tender mercies of the
terrorist group hamas and the gaza strip
zero there are two million people who
live under hamas
in israel 20 of the population is arab
minimum and rising and that is because
israel is tolerant and israel is
democratic and i am proud
of that as a westerner i am proud of the
fact that israel is humane
in the middle of wars israel is
attempting to minimize civilian
casualties
of a population that supported hamas by
pole statistics
that israel is attempting to avoid
killing civilians meanwhile its enemies
are attempting to shield their own
weapons with civilians
i am proud of the fact that israel
carries out its values in war and in
peace
and i'm proud of the fact that israel is
in fact
in an outlying area of western democracy
not because it is some sort of
colonialist outpost but because the jews
never left and because the root of the
west remains
through that judeo-christian line i am
proud of all those things
and because i'm proud of all those
things as an american and as a jew
i wear this yamaka and if you have a
problem with this you can
write off and i mean that to all the
semi to
the anti-semites who are out there all
the anti-semites
who want to suggest that jews
everywhere should be living in fear of
wearing a yamako or speaking their
values
which happen to be correct values
everyone out there who suggests that if
you support
israel you deserve to be treated as a
second-class citizen
or that israel itself ought to be
treated as a second-class country
i wear the yamaha because i stand
against all of that
and i know that there are tons of people
who are not jewish who believe the same
things
that i do and i'm so grateful for that i
get your notes
i get your letters of support i get that
the vast majority of americans
understand the truth
not only with regard to the israel arab
conflict
which of course is a foreign conflict
but also
they understand the underlying truth
about the nature
of jews living in the united states and
the reality of jewish values
and i say all of this to say that if
people fail to recognize
these basic truths that judeo-christian
values undergird
american values and western values and
liberties that we all enjoy
if people fail to recognize the basic
decency
of one state attempting to minimize
civilian casualties while another
terrorist group attempts to wipe every
jew it can off the planet
that if people fail to recognize this
and if they in fact forward this agenda
and if they cheer that agenda they are
complicit in the anti-semitic attacks
that we have seen
over the course of these weekends i'm
not saying they're responsible for those
attacks unless they only call for them
because i have a very strict standard
when it comes to quote-unquote
incitement
but you have raised the temperature
you've made it more comfortable
and that is what i am seeing okay i have
close relatives who live in new jersey
people in jews in new jersey were told
over the course of this weekend
that they were supposed to stay in their
homes over sabbath
that is un-american i have a lot of
friends in new york
who are walking around in groups because
they are afraid to walk around alone in
the city of new york in the united
states
these attacks are not fake these attacks
are not rare
jews historically in the united states
have been the number one target
of hate crimes in the united states but
that's constantly forgotten because of
course we now live in a world
in which victimization can be linked to
your historical dispossession so long
as your group is not well educated and
wealthy in the same way that
anti-anti-asian
sentiment went completely by the wayside
for years because asian americans
tend to be well-educated and wealthy
anti-semitism has gone by the wayside
unless it's a convenient club with which
to
beat people on the right the reality
today
is that institutionalized anti-semitism
lives on the american left
the truth is that the spate of
anti-semitic attacks that we've seen
over the course of the last week
is not coming from white supremacists
white supremacists are scary enough
believe me i've spoken up about them
just a couple of years ago the fbi
arrested a white supremacist attempting
to threaten and hurt my family
but the threat that we have seen over
the last week people in the streets
going around attempting to beat jews
that is not coming from white
supremacists
that is coming from a
a radical a radicalized islamic
population
backed by the american left in many ways
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video